so game of thrones actor peter dinklage
went on a podcast the other day and
declared that it was quote offensive and
backward that disney was planning to
hire real-life dwarves little people for
remake of the film snow white and the
seven dwarves listen
i was a little
taken back by the
very very they're very proud to cast a
a latino actress as snow white yeah but
you're still telling the story of snow
snow white yeah seven dwarfs sure
would look take a step back and look at
what you're doing there yeah i know that
makes no sense to me but oh so
you're progressive in one way and then
but you're still making that
backward oh story of seven dwarves
living in a cave what the are you
doing man
so in response to that podcast podcasts
have real power now the disney company
said it was quote rethinking its use of
dwarves in the snow white and the seven
dwarves remake
now some dwarf actors are asking who put
peter dinklage in charge of the dwarf
community dylan postal played
hornswoggle the leprechaun in the wwe
for 10 years he also acted in the
muppets he joins us
now thanks so much for joining us so you
so i think a lot of people hear this
podcast and they think well you know
here's a guy who's got the authority to
speak on this
and that's his view and no one kind of
questions it tell us what your reaction
to it was
i mean my biggest thing is is i
he wants to be progressive and it's all
about progression and i support that
completely but the issue is him being
progressive is eliminating seven
potential dream jobs right from the
dwarf acting community and that's that's
my issue here is
he's saying he wants to move forward and
do good for the community
when this these are dream jobs i got
hired by wwe
wwe was my dream job since i was four
years old since i was four years old all
i wanted to be was a wwe superstar
and
in in any other circumstance it wouldn't
have been
able to be done by me i'm not six foot
i'm not 250 pounds but they were looking
for a person like me a little person to
fill this role
they hired me and i got to live my dream
for 10 years
now
there's dwarf actors out there that
their dream is their dream is to
to to star in a in a film especially a
disney film because as we know
disney doesn't do
remakes or any of their movies at a
small scale they they were gonna blow
this movie up obviously
and these are seven roles
that are few and far between for dwarves
anyways that were made for us and that's
that's the
what's ridiculous to me about the whole
situation is
it's not being progressive you're
hurting the community by what you're
doing you make a really good point and
and the film is called seven
you know snow white and the seven dwarfs
so i mean if there was ever a place it
might be
all right it's not snow white in the
seven normal-sized humans i get that we
have to be progressive we have to move
forward but
you're changing one of the most known
fairy tales and one of the most known
disney adaptations of all time
why
and also i i hate to say it and
the king dwarf thing i said and i mean
that who put this guy in charge and why
is he
the single voice like for a whole
community
for a whole community of people
i can argue i was on tv for 10 years i
was in film not at the scale he was but
why why because he throws the red flag
is everything stopped and that's such a
great point what upsets me is
so one guy has an opinion on a on a
podcast and he gets to take control of
your career going forward that's a
little strange so have you met with i
mean i think you make a very fair point
have you met with disney
i have not and i would absolutely love
to and i would absolutely love giving my
opinion as well as a i've had people
from the dwarf community reach out to me
saying how this is crazy that that to
recast or to to make it you know
normal humans or normal sides i i use
that term uh but normal humans
and normal sized humans
for these roles it's just it's it's
insane to me and it's just it just
doesn't make any sense um i say it all
the time
disney i know
six dwarf actors
with myself that would love these roles
i'll play sleepy or grumpy or whoever
or i'll be a stunt double for one of
them for all i care i
these are dream roles literally made for
our community and i just think it's it's
crazy to to recast it
you make such a good point it's a
metaphor a small number of unhappy
people get to record for everyone dylan
i hope you get exactly the role that you
want and i hope you reach disney thank
you for coming on tonight
thank you very much for your time hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else